if you're sitting in a movie theater
during previews and you see if this you
know to expect a comedy movie if you see
this you know it's gonna be action make
the letters a little skinny and boom
it's sci-fi you know this one's gonna
have best cars this one's gonna have
Michael Cera and this one is gonna be a
rom-com you don't even need the music to
know it but what about this this
typeface Trajan is probably one of the
most popular movie poster fonts ever you
can see it in Crouching Tiger Hidden
Dragon
double jeopardy it's everywhere so how
did it get there
[Music]
I'm Eve Peters I'm a graphic designer
who has been writing professionally
about type and typography since about 10
years eve has looked at a lot of posters
and a few years ago he started to notice
a trend so I started clicking and
clicking clicking I didn't know what I
started because I ended up looking at
about 60,000 yeah well I look at about a
hundred posters per month and I've been
doing this series since 2006 it's it's a
lot of posters every year yeah he
noticed that the use of Trajan rose
significantly in the last couple of
decades but why
in 1989 designer Karol Twombly adapted
inscriptions from Roman Emperor Trajan's
column into a digital typeface it was
made for Adobe so it was a part of the
software that a lot of people were
starting to use to make posters a couple
years later it made its movie poster
debut here for hector babenco x' at play
in the fields of the Lord after that it
was on the bodyguard and Scent of a
Woman
then it was on 3 1993 box-office hits by
1994 it was everywhere
it's originally used for epic movies
movies about people that overcome
difficulties I could make war epics and
so on but then you see gradually that it
becomes the standard movie fault it's
like the aerial of movie posters so
people need to turn out a poster really
quickly and just big Trajan eventually
that overuse started to change the kinds
of movies that would use the typeface
you don't see that much on the big
productions anymore it's become the
typeface of the horror movies the B
movies and also the straight-to-video
ones so you see that a lot of posters
are for the lesser movies that want to
pretend they are better than they
actually are
the rise and fall of Trajan illustrates
the downside of digital typeface the
convenience of swapping fonts is a huge
shift from the old movie poster days
when hand-painted typefaces or lettering
was an art that was specific to each
movie so what you see behind me this is
more like the pre blockbuster say free
genres free standard styles and that's
why you will be hard-pressed to find two
that are similar
that doesn't make today's genre-specific
typography bad design these visual
cliches make it possible to communicate
tone and plot details to an audience
incredibly efficiently and there's a
certain art to that people get nostalgic
about the old era of movie posters when
everything was still done by hand and
still very unique but you could compare
to music where some people say oh
nothing was nothing good was produced
since the wheels but then as our people
said nothing good was produced since
bows are fair enough
but there's many other interesting
things there are be produced now there's
just much more but there's still a lot
of very good poster design happening
it's just you need to know where to look
[Music]